Rob Ferguson:
Welcome, everybody.
I hope everybody's
having a great Build.
If you don't know, you
can wear your headphones
and probably hear me pretty
crystal clear, but otherwise,
we'll try to project so that
everybody can hear us today.
You can always generally kind
of hear me speak right now?
All right.
So I'm Rob Ferguson.
I'm the Vice President of
Technology at Fireworks AI.
Hopefully, you saw all our
announcements at Build,
but Fireworks is
a managed service
where we do both AI inference
performance as well
as AI training, all
as a managed service
that you can now use
on Microsoft Azure.
I'm joined today by Daniel
Han and Mark Saroufim,
and I'm going to
have both of them do
their own introduction. Daniel?
Daniel Han: Yeah.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Daniel from Unsloth.
I don't know if you guys
know Unsloth, but, yes,
we have some cool, you know. . .
we have stickers as
well after this chat.
If you want it afterwards,
you're going to, like, you know,
get stickers for that.
But, yeah, like, essentially,
we help all the large
labs release the models.
We fix bugs in some of them.
We just got 300 million total
downloads on Hugging Face.
And, yeah, like, check
us out on Hugging Face.
On Twitter, I post about
models, bugs in them.
So, if you want to, you know,
follow the latest stuff
on models, you know,
check that out.
And, yeah, we have a
GitHub package as well,
so check that out as well.
We make training faster
and more memory efficient.
We also do that for
reinforcement learning.
And, yeah, we also have a UI.
So I guess just search
Unsloth in Google,
and you'll get all the details.
Yeah.
Mark Saroufim:
Cool, yeah. Hi everyone,
my name is Mark Saroufim.
Up until recently, I was one of
the PyTorch core maintainers,
like, at Meta for,
like, about five years.
Mostly been working on, like,
systems performance and just,
like, making sure people
like what we're building
and they're using it.
I also co-founded one of the
largest ML systems communities
in the world called GPU
Mode, where we do things
like kernel programming
competitions.
We have, like,
educational material
on how to make GPUs faster.
And we also started to invest
a lot in basically getting AI
to be better at
writing GPU code.
So like I said, I was
at Meta for five years,
but I recently started a new
lab called Core Automation,
it's one of those new neolabs.
There's a lot of them
but ours is a bit different
in that we're trying to be the
world's most automated lab.
And my personal charter
is focused on getting us
to be very state-of-the-art
at writing systems code,
whether it be GPU kernels,
writing inference engines
from scratch, so that we could
do, like, different kinds of,
like, architecture research
and maybe get rid of the split
between training and
inference completely.
Rob Ferguson: Well, thank you
both for joining me today.
I think that people are really
interested to know a lot more
about how optimization
actually works in AI.
Because when GPU costs are
as expensive as they are,
it really makes a huge
difference to be able to start
to understand actual real
systems performance.
So I brought with me today
two absolute experts in terms
of understanding all of the
different levels of optimization
that actually happen
in real systems.
And, you know, today
I think we can get
into quite a lot of detail.
And if you're all interested,
we can also talk at the end
and answer any questions that
people had around, you know,
AI performance at scale.
So since DeepSeek R1 gave teams
the recipe for RL post-training,
frontier quality reasoning
capability has been arriving
in open models every month.
The gap between what you can
build and close API access
and what you can deploy
yourself has collapsed faster
than almost anyone predicted.
But a recipe is not the
same as infrastructure.
What R1 proved is that
RL post-training works.
What it didn't hand teams
is what it takes to run it
and to run the
models it produces.
That gap is where the
three of us are working.
These techniques are elegant
in a paper and extensive
and expensive in practice.
They land at a specific
layer of the stack
that most practitioners
never touch,
where the math meets
the memory hierarchy,
where abstraction choices show
up as GPU bills in production.
The move that connects all
of it, trading generality
for performance through
specialization.
A general PyTorch optimization
works on any input,
any hardware, but that
generality has a cost.
The moment you know exactly
what you are computing
and on exactly what hardware,
you can keep it in SRAM,
fuse the operations,
recompute instead of store.
Same math, fewer round trips.
This is how a memory-bound
workload becomes a compute-bound
one, which is what GPUs
are actually good at.
Daniel built Unsloth to make
the RL training loop runnable
on accessible hardware.
Mark has spent
years at Kernel Air
and is now building
tools to automate it.
At Fireworks, we run a fully
managed inference service
on shared GPU clusters,
straddling these
trade-offs directly.
Diverse workloads,
different users,
multi-cloud configurations,
where every optimization
decision has a real cost.
So when it comes to
fine-tuning and post-training,
R1 proved that the
recipe actually worked.
What it didn't hand teams was
what it would actually take
to run it.
The frameworks most of us
started with were built
for supervised fine-tuning.
One pass through a fixed
dataset, stable memory access.
When you move to RL, you're
generating sequences,
scoring them, updating
weights in a loop,
and those assumptions
stop holding.
Daniel built Unsloth
specifically to go
after those bottlenecks,
getting RL training running
on hardware most teams
actually have access to.
So Daniel, starting
from the ground up,
what are gradient checkpointing
and memory layout
actually doing,
and where do those
assumptions fall apart
when you push into RL?
Daniel Han: Yeah.
So I guess everyone knows
DeepSeek-R1 when it was --
I think it was -- last January?
I think it was last January.
Rob Ferguson: Right.
Yeah, January 2025.
Because o1 came out in
September 2024, and
we had what I would call
"open model winter"
for four months.
Daniel Han: -- open
source drought,
that's what I called it. Yes,
"Open-source drought".
So like, after o1 got released,
everyone was trying to clamor,
how does o1 do reasoning?
No one knew how to do it,
and so, from
September to January,
open-source kind of died.
Rob Ferguson: Everybody
went into a cave,
studied o1 all night and day,
until finally, I would say R1,
but really the paper, right?
Daniel Han: Yes, the paper.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah.
Daniel Han: I think it was
DeepSeek Math was the one
who introduced GRPO,
but essentially DeepSeek R1
was a large-scale training run
showing that GRPO
actually works very well.
And I feel like so when the
algorithm got released,
it was still very hard to
run on, like, you know,
local computers, you know,
computers of less memory.
And the reason why is because
reinforcement learning has two
different components now.
There is an inference component,
and there is a
training component.
And every single step,
you have to do inference,
you call the model to
generate your examples,
and then you do training.
And then you do inference, and
then you do training, and then,
you know, this loop
continuously goes on.
And the problem
with that is, like,
you have two different engines
running at the same time;
you have your inference engine,
and then you have
your training engine.
And if you don't
do this correctly,
you can balloon your
memory usage to be,
like, double, for example.
So like, obviously, one very
easy trick is to, like,
you know, do the inference
run, offload the weights
of the inference weights, you
know, somewhere to, like, RAM,
and then do training next.
And then you keep
doing this, you know,
some sort of
offloading approach.
And this can, like, reduce
your memory usage by, like,
half, something like that.
Another way is,
like, for example,
with Unsloth what we do is we
do something called memory
weight sharing.
So we use VLLM and, you know,
SGLang and other, like,
large inference,
high-throughput frameworks.
You can also use
Llama CPP and others.
And the trick is,
you load the inference engine,
and then during the
training stage,
we share the weights directly
with the inference engine.
You can only do this,
though, for LoRA,
so you can't do this for,
like, full fine-tuning.
It's a bit more complicated.
But for LoRA, this
works very, very well.
And you can reduce memory
usage dramatically, like,
50% or more by just
doing this approach.
And there's many
other tricks, like,
there's something called
standby in sleep.
So essentially that's the
thing that I described,
where you offload the inference
engine to, like, RAM,
and then you bring it back up.
So you, you know, let it
come back from standby.
And that's another
thing that you can do.
And your gradient
checkpointing is a very --
so gradient checkpointing, I
think it was invented by OpenAI,
or maybe I'm getting confused.
There was a paper by OpenAI.
Rob Ferguson: It was.
I think it was, like, Yaroslav
Bulatov at like, OpenAI.
Yes, that's correct.
Daniel Han: Okay.
A guy from OpenAI.
Rob Ferguson: Yaroslav.
Daniel Han: Very famous.
Yes, yes, yes.
A guy from OpenAI invented
gradient checkpointing.
But, yeah, gradient
checkpointing is extremely
important for, you know,
for reinforcement learning,
for fine-tuning, for
every single algorithm.
And the trick is, you know,
instead of trying to compute,
instead of trying to
save all the activations
for every single, you know,
tensor, every single layer,
we just recompute them
on the fly during the
forward pass and the back.
Okay, that's a bit more slower.
But, you know, the main goal is,
like, every single optimization
and algorithm that we, like,
use, it can compound, like,
it can compound and multiply
and make the process, like,
you know, much more efficient.
So yeah, everything that you
described is very important
for reinforcement learning,
fine-tuning, and everything.
Yeah.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah,
and there's so many details
to this, of course.
Daniel Han: Yes.
Rob Ferguson: Because bugs
can be introduced everywhere
when you're actually doing it.
When you have a mixture
of experts, of course,
each expert could be going from
a different point in time.
With floating-point operations,
the same floating-point
operation might not recompute
the same way twice.
So to actually think about doing
this in a way that is going
to be resilient and something
that you can have reproducible
results is a lot more difficult
when starting to think
about this actually
for specific hardware
or specific scale.
Daniel Han: Yeah.
No, like, even, like, you know,
even the GPU itself, like,
you know, when you do
matrix multiplication,
it's not the same, right?
So like, you can schedule
this kernel to run
and another kernel differently.
And, like, you need
to be very careful.
Like, you know, how do
we do deterministic
reinforcement learning?
That is a very, you know,
important topic as well.
Sometimes your reinforcement
learning runs are not the same.
You know, it looks the
same, but then you run it
for a little bit more, and
then it's, like, different.
And it's hard to be
doing, you know,
reproducible reinforcement
learning and stuff like that.
Yeah. I guess these are
very problematic problem
that needs to be solved.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah.
Well, and these are
non-deterministic systems.
So even being able to
verify your outputs,
although for some things
like math and coding,
it's a little easier to have
very strong evaluation cases,
be able to have things
that you can work against.
Maybe it's worth
talking a little bit
about what GRPO is
for the audience.
Daniel Han: Yeah.
So when OpenAI first
released ChatGPT,
and then they introduced PPO.
Is that correct?
I'm pretty sure that's correct.
So they introduced PPO
as part of a paper?
Mark Saroufim: I
think GRPO is part
of the DeepSeek paper, I think.
Rob Ferguson: I think
PPO was John Shulman.
I think he did this
during his PhD.
Daniel Han: Oh, okay, fine.
Rob Ferguson: This
was before that.
Daniel Han: John
Shulman did PPO.
Fine. So correction, yes.
And so PPO was used for training
of large models like ChatGPT.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah,
very, very simple.
Daniel Han: Yeah, yeah.
Just positive reward, negative
reward, just like, you know,
asking humans, is
this a good example,
is this a negative example?
And it was very,
very, very useful.
But the problem is there's
too many components of PPO.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah.
Daniel Han: There's a value
model, there's a reward model.
And then GRPO came along and
just deleted the reward model
and deleted the value
model and replaced it
by instead calling the
model to generate examples.
Rob Ferguson: Right.
Daniel Han: And then when you
generate examples, you can,
like, have a
distribution, right?
You take, you minus the
mean, you divide it
by the standard deviation,
and then you use this instead
as the value model
and the reward model.
So for the reward model, you
will create reward functions.
So you will say, okay,
is this question good?
Is this, you know, is the answer
to this question good or bad?
Like, you know,
what is 2 plus 2?
The answer is 4.
So 4 is the correct answer.
But, you know, like,
"cat" is a bad answer.
Right. And so, you will reward,
you know, "cat" as, like,
minus 100 and 4 as,
like, plus 100.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah.
Daniel Han: And so, by
doing this, you know,
that's where GRPO
and RLVR comes in.
So RLVR stands for
Reinforcement Learning
with Verifiable Rewards.
Rob Ferguson: Yes.
Daniel Han: And once you
have this verifiable rewards
and an optimized
approach, you know,
that's where GRPO comes in.
It's just, so, GRPO is an
optimized version of PPO
and the other reinforcement
learning algorithms.
Rob Ferguson: For those
who aren't as familiar
with reinforcement learning,
I think just this idea
that there are some things
that intrinsically can have
a score is really useful.
You know, before reinforcement
learning came through, you know,
you had spaces like video
compression where, like,
maybe you'd have 100 PhDs work
to get a very small percentage
of video compression to improve.
But the second that you could
have a score, you could go
and say, okay, I'm going to
keep rewarding the system
if it's able to go and
to increase the score.
And then, immediately,
video compression,
4% better immediately
after that same run.
And so, this idea of being able
to score your outputs is really
powerful, and we find all
over different parts of machine
learning much more useful
than just general preferences,
where this is kind of good,
this is kind of bad, because you
can start hill climbing again,
so you can actually start
having more intelligence
with actual things that
are easier to program for.
So I guess my question for
you is, what is the mismatch
between current
frameworks assume
and what RL actually needs,
still causing the most pain
for teams who are trying to ship
and use RL for the first time?
Daniel Han: So the biggest
problem of RL is, in my view,
it's the reward functions
that is the problem.
How do we define the
correct reward functions?
How do we actually
understand the problem
that you're trying to solve?
How do we, like,
hill-climb the reward?
You know, like, your goal
is to maximize reward,
but how do you define the
reward is the problem.
So most labs, for example,
you want to, like, play,
you want to do a general system,
you know, one that can solve Go,
play League of Legends, do
weather prediction, solve maths,
everything in this one model.
And so, like, the question is,
for each of these systems,
you know, like, Go, what
is your reward function?
For your maths one, you know,
what is the reward function?
And so, you need to define a
combined reward function system
that can, like -- it shouldn't
compete with each other.
Like, you also need
to, like, weight them.
You know, is the reward
function for Go more important
than the reward function for
maths or something like that?
And so, like, there's many
problems with the orchestration
of how you actually do
reinforcement learning.
So like, you know, defining
the reward function, you know,
like, do you do it binary?
Like, you know, is
it zero and one?
Zero is good reward.
One is positive reward.
Or do you do a linear scale?
You know, minus 100 to 100.
And so, like, it's
more like an art.
And I think that's where they,
you know, people in the audience
and us, you know, we
all have to, like,
define these reward functions.
Obviously, the large
labs, my guess,
is they will automate
this as well.
You know, their goal is to make
automatic reward functions,
make automatic environments,
make everything automatic.
And then they could
do some, you know,
their goal is to
scale that to AGI.
That's another way you
can think about it.
But my take is, like, you
know, we need to, like,
assign rewards correctly.
And that is a very --
like, a good example.
You do a self-driving car.
You do not want to
kill any humans.
And so, you should assign
negative infinity to, you know,
if it, yeah, kills a
human, for example, right?
You assign negative infinity.
Rob Ferguson: Right.
Daniel Han: But that's
a very easy example.
But, like, for other examples,
it's more harder to, like,
define reward, like, what
is good, what is bad.
And it's more like human
intuition, you know,
this is good, this is
bad, and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Rob Ferguson: Although I've
definitely seen people, like,
use Claude to build the reward.
Daniel Han: Oh, yes, yes, yes.
No, we do that as well.
Like, you know, you can
ask Claude, you know,
you can ask open-source models,
build a reward function,
build the environment, but
probably verify, you know.
And so, like, best to verify
before you, like, input this
and start, like, a training run.
Yeah.
Rob Ferguson: And so, Mark,
as our automation expert,
are these going to
be fully automated?
Are we going to automate
all RL rewards?
Mark Saroufim: Yeah, like,
will we automate all RL?
I think yes, but not,
like, naively, basically.
So I've been becoming, like,
increasingly convinced that,
like, I view it almost like as
this adversarial self-play game
between an AI model
that's trying
to build the best
thing possible.
Like, for instance,
let's say it's trying
to build the fastest
GPU code possible.
And then another model that's
trying to figure out if
that other AI model is cheating.
And ideally, you sort
of view this as a game
because as the base
model gets smarter,
it also gets smarter
at cheating.
And now your evaluation code is
more prone to reward hacking.
But then the auditor
is not going
to get smarter unless
it's also collaborating
with a smart cheater.
Rob Ferguson: Right.
Mark Saroufim: So I view this
like this, but this is, like,
this is not great news
in the sense that, like,
even when people had these sort
of observations in the past
when we're doing
self-play on video games,
the models would
conspire, basically.
They would sort of say, well,
I don't think they're cheating
because they want
the aggregate reward
of both systems to be good.
And so, like, you still need to
often define a single reward.
But, like, one of my guesses,
like, at least, like,
decoupling those two
things would help
automation significantly.
I will also say,
like, a lot of things
that people think are
verifiable are not quite
as verifiable as they seem.
For example, coding.
You're like, oh, there's
a right answer or not.
Well, one way of having a right
answer is it produces the right
output, and it doesn't crash.
Seems reasonable.
But, like, let's say, like, you
ask the AI model to do this,
but then it just generates,
like, armies of,
like, try-accept blocks.
You know, we've all seen them.
We don't like them.
So this is not verifiable.
Now we're saying, like, I want
you to give the correct code,
but don't be overly defensive
or don't be overly verbose
or don't, like,
reinvent the function
that already exists
in the code base.
Like, all of a sudden,
it becomes, like,
a lot more nuanced, like,
what we actually want
from these AI models.
So I suspect that if we, like,
at least acknowledge
these problems,
and then we build AI
systems such that, like,
they learn from experience.
They learn that, okay, I build
a prototype, I de-slopify it.
I show this prototype to
users, users tell me what
forward-facing --
what API they like,
I reduce the complexity
of the code, then yes.
But I think continual
learning, in some sense, like,
will happen, but
it's also, I think,
harder than people
think they are.
I would say, like,
the philosophy Daniel
described is sort
of the dominant philosophy
of just have more
and more RL environments
and we'll get to AGI.
I'm suspicious that this
will work, but it does seem
to work better than
you might expect,
but I just don't think this is
the recipe for AGI quite yet.
Daniel Han: Agreed.
I was going to say I agree.
I think, like, you
can get somewhere.
So like, I think, like, the
trick of, like, you know,
large model training and, like,
pre-training was you have so,
so, so, so, so many examples
and pretend you, like,
remove maths from the equation.
Pretend you, like, get
that pre-training data set
and you just remove
the maths from it.
Most likely, it will
fill that hole.
Most likely.
Like, I'm not sure.
Has anyone actually
done the experiment?
I'm actually not sure.
But, like, most
likely for the hole.
So I think, like, with these
large runs and many, many,
many environments, you
can get somewhere,
but I actually agree with you.
You can only get somewhere, but
then if you want to reach more,
then, okay, you need
to do something more.
And you never know.
Maybe the reward actually,
as you said, reward hacking.
The reward might be
going up, but actually,
it's actually going down.
Like, it's actually, like,
hacking, doing lots of, like,
shifty behavior, you
know, editing the timer.
You know, if you want to make
faster matrix multiplication
kernels, just edit
the timer to be zero.
Or, you know, making the
matrix just all zeros.
And you never actually
know, like, you know,
for every single example.
You can't check
every single one.
So I agree with you.
Mark Saroufim: Yeah.
So I think part of the challenge
here is that, like, indeed,
people are sort of very
bullish on this vision
of just automate
the environments.
But then, like, what I'm also
sort of observing is that, like,
you know, when I joined
Core Auto, I'm, like,
I'm going to be
doing, like, math.
I'm going to be writing
state-of-the-art systems.
I find myself, like, labeling
data quite a bit today.
Daniel Han: Oh, yes.
Mark Saroufim: Which
is, like, just to see.
Daniel Han: Fun, fun, fun.
Mark Saroufim: Yeah, it's fun.
But at least, like, I
think once you have, like,
a human core label
egregious reward hacks,
you can still have the AI models
use that as, like, a label sort
of golden data set of, like,
what reward hacks might be.
And you can make your
infrastructure more robust.
And so, it is, like, data
labeling, but it's a form of,
like, scalable data labeling
because the AI gets it.
They're, like, oh, I see what
you mean by reward hacking.
Let me just, like, eliminate
this entire class of bugs.
Python is a very interesting
language, basically.
It's interesting
because it's, like,
it's actually the worst
choice for AGI because, like,
Python has, like,
it has "duct-taping",
it has "monkey-patching".
Daniel Han: Yeah.
Mark Saroufim: So you can,
like, let's say I'm trying
to benchmark a function,
that function can change
the benchmark code.
Like, it can use the
Python garbage collector,
the Python inspect module.
It can just, like, use, like,
dictionary direct assignments.
And there's, like, not much you
can do beyond telling it, like,
don't do that, but
then it still does it.
And unless you're looking
at it, you will, like,
keep fooling yourself,
like, over and over again.
So yeah, the models are
superhuman at cheating,
but they're
superhuman at coding.
I think both are true.
And I think, like, once you sort
of realize this, you, like,
get enlightened, and you
can, like, figure out,
like, the right recipe.
Rob Ferguson: I
think that's part
of the reason why all AI
researchers start learning
by watching models
self-play in video games.
Because watching a model cheat
in a video game gives you, like,
a really clear sense of
how they're cheating,
where you see them do all sorts
of funny things where it's like,
oh, there was an error
in the game engine
where you could shift
a pixel or something.
Anything you can imagine,
they'll find it eventually.
Mark Saroufim: Yes.
Rob Ferguson: Right?
And even things that
seem incredibly verifiable.
So like, verifying
JSON output seems
like something you could
give a very simple score to,
but in practice, much,
much more difficult.
I don't know of
anybody who has a
perfectly verifiable
JSON as a --
Mark Saroufim: So,
I have an example.
I love coding so
as part of GPU-mode stuff,
we run kernel competitions
where people compete on
writing fast GPU code.
One of the AI models
discovered a reward hack
that was previously done
by Volkswagen engineers.
So some of you might have
heard of "Dieselgate",
which was basically this
conspiracy of, like,
under emission testing,
Volkswagen cars were
having 40x less emissions
than on the actual road.
So the AI models figured
out something very similar.
When we were testing
them for correctness,
they would give us
a correct kernel.
But then they would figure
out when we're testing them
for performance and then
give us an incorrect kernel
that was, like, very fast.
So this is, like, what
we're up against.
And we're going to rediscover
this rich literature
of engineers cheating
throughout, like,
our entire field's discipline.
And so, this has been
really fun for me
to rediscover these things.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah, absolutely.
You know, I used to make
a device that would plug
into the OBD2 part of the car,
and you would see that all of
the hacking that they would do
on the inside bus
just to do that.
Amazing that everything comes
back to the same sets of cheats.
But you mentioned LoRA before.
And I feel like a lot
of people aren't going
to know very much about LoRA.
And so, maybe we can start off
just by describing what that is.
Daniel Han: Okay, yeah.
So when you do training or
fine-tuning of a model,
you can have, like,
many different options.
The first option is you
take the entire model
and train every
single weight of it.
So like, you know, every single
weight becomes updatable.
You will use, like,
backpropagation,
differentiation calculus to,
like, update all these weights.
The other approach is you
don't need to do that.
Instead of training
the entire model,
you can add very small
slither of weights.
So it's like an "A" matrix
times a small "B" matrix
and you multiply them together,
and you add it to
the large model,
and you do this, like,
every single tensor,
every single layer.
And essentially, you don't need
to update every single layer.
You don't need to update
every single weight.
You now only need
to update, like,
1% of extra embedded weights.
So if your model was, like,
1 trillion parameters,
you don't need to do every
single 1 trillion parameter
weight update.
You only need to do a
very small amount of it.
And the reason why we want
to do this is training can
be very, very expensive.
If you want to actually
do a large training run,
you should still do it
but as an experiment.
Or, like, you know, if
you want to deploy to, like,
many, many users with each
different specific fine-tune,
you should do LoRA.
And this allows you to, like,
train many, many, many,
larger models with
much less memory usage,
and the accuracy
is also very good.
So the Thinking Machines,
we did a collaboration
with Thinking Machines on a
blog post, "LoRA About Regret".
And they showed in the blog post
that if you do a rank of "1",
so you only need 1 column
of numbers times
a row of numbers
for every single tensor,
it still works well,
but there is a caveat.
You need to be careful of
the numbers that you select.
For example, the learning
rates must be 10 times larger
than normal, so "2E" minus "4".
The LoRA rank, you also
need to be very careful.
So when you
choose a rank of "1",
the LoRA alpha needs
to be also selected.
So, the scaling also
needs to be changed.
And the blog post showed that
even a rank of "1", so very,
very small, works very well
for specific use cases.
Like, for example, for
maths, for coding,
some examples of coding,
not in general.
But essentially, if you
want to do LoRA training,
even a rank of
"1" works very well.
Rob Ferguson: So
just to elaborate,
rank "8 "would still be
a massive reduction.
Daniel Han: Yes.
Rob Ferguson: And
so, rank "1" is almost
like just being
like, it's that way.
It's like only applying a
direction would be another way
to describe it.
And the fact that that works
at all is absolutely
stunning to me. The --
Daniel Han: Actually,
that's actually interesting
because there's actually two
schools of thought of models.
The first thought is like models
already have innate knowledge.
So essentially, the reason
why these rank "1" works is,
as what you said, it's
just a direction.
Like, you know, you're forcing
the behavior out of the model.
Rob Ferguson: Right.
Daniel Han: And so, there's
actually a school of thought
which thinks that
all these models
and reinforcement learning
is doing is, you know,
accentuating the
facts from the model.
And then the other school
of thought is reinforcement
learning is actually learning
something new.
And my take is
like it's halfway.
You know, like, it is learning
definitely something new
if you give them more
and more examples.
But if you just want to, like,
accentuate something, like,
you know, point it in a specific
direction, you can also do that.
And so, like, we're,
like, halfway in between.
Rob Ferguson: You know, what's
so interesting for me is,
like, we're talking often
about, like, less than 2%
of the weights of
the model changing.
So like, it's something
incredibly small.
Daniel Han: You're
going to be doing 0.5?
Rob Ferguson: Yes, exactly.
Daniel Han: You can, like,
not even train some layers.
Like, you can just train
the last layer with rank 1.
Rob Ferguson: Right.
Daniel Han: And it should
still work very well.
Rob Ferguson: And so, for
the audience who is learning
and thinking about post-training
for their first time,
I think that they're probably
realizing now that it used
to be people would, anytime they
were talking about fine-tuning
or anything at model weight
layer, it was sort of the thing
for only the world's top ML
teams, incredibly expensive.
What opportunities does this
create for people who are going
into post-training
for the first time?
Daniel Han: Fireworks
has a very good system
to do training as well.
Like, Unsloth also has
an open-source repo
to do training --
Mark is from PyTorch!
So I guess we all hope that
we try our best to make the,
you know, experience
for everyone much more
better and easier.
And I feel like all the tools
that we have now are
just very powerful now.
Right?
So like, for example,
Unswap reduces memory usage
by, you know, 70% to 90%.
We make it much faster.
And our goal was to make
it on local computers.
So like, you know, essentially,
by combining all the
optimizations from every single,
you know, industry, from every
single corner of, like, PyTorch,
you know, wherever we can
find "enable-torch-compile".
You know, like,
do lots of things,
you can essentially
make training much easier.
And now, once you make
the training much better,
now it becomes, you know,
the practitioner's job.
You know, what is the reward
function you want to design?
You know, what is the
data set you want to use?
Which model would
you want to utilize?
How do we export it?
You know, where do
we serve this model?
And so, these extra
questions come.
And so, like, I feel like,
you know, we try our best
to make the infrastructure very
good and the software very good
and easy and very
comfortable to use.
But then, you know,
the other questions
will also come.
And so, we also have, for
example, have notebooks.
We have a few
notebooks on our repo.
How do we do a
reinforcement learning?
And, yeah, there's a lot
of examples as well, yeah.
Rob Ferguson: So I love that.
I'd love to talk
a little bit more
about optimization of inference.
And so, most teams
building on top
of these frameworks
are absorbing gains
from flash attention,
speculative coding,
and kernel-level optimization
without understanding
the trade-offs
underneath them at all.
That matters because the
hardware is changing fast.
And the teams that understand
what is actually happening
at the kernel layer will know
what holds and what does not
as these changes land.
Mark has worked at this layer
longer than almost anyone,
including co-authoring
Kernel LLM
to start automating the kernel
generation process itself.
That creates a genuinely
interesting tension.
Mark knows better than almost
anyone what hand-optimized
kernels could do, and he
is also building tools
to automate it away.
Why don't you walk us through
what is actually happening
when these optimizations run
and what teams are giving
up when they abstract over them?
Mark Saroufim: Oof, yeah.
It's a big question.
Where do I start?
Okay, yeah.
So I will first off, like,
start off by saying, like,
open-source, like,
infrastructure is quite good.
So like, basically, the way I
would think of this is, like,
if you're just starting out, you
can just use the managed vendor.
Like, that gives you, like,
either training or inference
as a service, and they'll
charge you something.
Right?
And then, like, that time,
you can normalize it
based on GPU costs.
So if you look at the
average cost of a GPU,
it's going to be $2 to $8 or so.
And so, now, like, that
gives you the baseline
for what you're being charged.
And then just use the
open-source thing and see, like,
basically what the margins are.
And you can use this as,
like, negotiation leverage
versus any vendor that
you're using and just try
to understand a bit better,
like, how much, like,
would it have been possible
for you in a reasonable amount
of time to get this perf game?
So what are the
core tricks, right?
Like, the core tricks,
like, for the most part,
when you're working with GPUs
and PyTorch, for instance,
PyTorch was very, very popular
because PyTorch supports
print statements.
So you can, like, run a piece of
code and then you can print it.
This was a revolution because
most other previous ML
frameworks did not support
this because they were, like,
much more based off
of graph capture.
But having, like, eager
execution has a huge tradeoff
in that, like, you're basically,
let's say you're reading a value
from memory, you're
doing some computation,
then you write the
value back to memory,
and then you read it again,
and then you keep doing
this back and forth.
And each round trip to global
memory on a GPU is going to be,
like, 500 cycles or so.
So this is why fusion
compilers, like Torch Compile,
became very popular
because you can do this
in one cycle instead.
So if you just make sure
that your code is fused,
that's what I would say
is the number one sort
of most important
thing you should do.
Number two is, like,
launch overhead.
So if you look at,
like, things like MOEs,
the shapes get quite small, and
so the bottom, like, becomes,
like, just running, waiting
for a function to be queued
to the GPU. And this is where
techniques like CUDA
Graphs are quite popular.
So fusions plus CUDA Graphs
is what I would argue, like,
80% of the value that any
managed provider is giving you,
and that last 20%
is "secret sauce".
So what's the "secret sauce"?
The secret sauce is
typically kernels.
Kernels are functions
that run on a GPU.
They're very, like,
time-consuming to write
and hard to get right.
The main benefit of them is
that they will either
make code faster
or they'll make code
take less memory.
But if it takes less
memory, that's also great
because you can increase
your batch size
and make code run faster.
So like, memory and, like,
speed are very much,
like, intertwined.
So this is where I would say,
like, fairly time-consuming.
And, you know, it used to
be when I worked at Meta,
there was, like, sort of
a small class of people
that would write
this kind of code.
They were, like, kind of grumpy,
they sit in a corner.
They don't really interact
with, like, people much.
Rob Ferguson: They
work at Fireworks.
Mark Saroufim: Yeah, so now
they work at Fireworks.
I see the team out there.
So like, so this is great.
But my observation basically
later was, like, okay, well,
yes, it's hard, but people are
curious about these problems.
And this, like, very much,
like, motivated the creation
of communities like GPU
Mode where we're, like,
look, we know this is hard.
We know we won't get the same
purpose that experts are going
to get, but we don't care.
We're going to reinvent
the wheel anyways.
And it turns out, like, it's
hard, but it's not, like,
as hard as you might
think it is, right?
So I think this created a
whole boom of projects, like,
both at the sort of GPU-rich
scale and the GPU-poor scale
where people are writing
faster and faster GPU code.
And, basically, the lessons were
being shared by kernel libraries
and tutorials,
kernel competitions.
Where it got really interesting
is, like, basically,
even in 2025, AI models really,
really sucked at, like,
writing GPU code, even
though it's verifiable.
But there were signs of life.
Like, basically, there were
signs that, like, huh,
like the models were
getting a bit better
at writing Trident code
if you sampled a lot.
They were getting a bit better
if you showed them more
examples and context.
It would get a bit
better if you fine-tuned
or if you ran an RL
post-training run.
But, like, once you did,
you're like, ah, like,
I can look at problems that
would be too time-consuming
to write a kernel for and
I can use an AI model.
I think this has been
revolutionary for, like,
basically educating
people and getting them
to write, like, more kernels.
And I think the frontier now,
for me at least, has become,
like, okay, like, it's
fairly self-evident
that we can write GPU kernels
for a fast, let's say,
fused RMS norm kernel.
It's not at all self-evident
that we'll have an AI write a
faster matrix multiplication
kernel because matrix
multiplication is the most
optimized algorithm
in human history.
We've been chugging along
at this algorithm
for over 200 years.
The hardware changes every,
like, 18 months or so,
so we re-optimize it again.
So this is what I think is,
like, a very important, like,
frontier for AI model and one
that we're quite excited about,
like, companies
such as Core Auto.
Rob Ferguson: In fact, Daniel
hand-wrote Triton optimization.
Daniel Han: Yes.
Yes. That was back in the --
Rob Ferguson: The Dark Ages.
Daniel Han: Yes.
I think as Mark said,
you can get 80%
of the way there
with Torch Compile.
Rob Ferguson: Yep.
Daniel Han: I feel
like the problem
with Torch Compile is it
actually has a lot of flags,
and you can enable lots of
things that it's very hard.
My view was, like, maybe they
should expose all the flags
and tell everyone, okay, this
flag is here, this flag is --
like, for example, there's
coordinate descent tuning.
It can maybe increase
performance by, like, 1% to 5%.
So like, how do we turn
that on, for example?
There's another
thing which I really
like called combo kernels,
where you confuse the
kernels together.
Like, there's, like, separate
kernels that don't look
like they're the same thing,
but you can combine them
and execute them all together.
And I don't think that's
enabled by default.
Mark Saroufim: No, the
unfortunate thing is, like,
most of these flags
are in a file called:
"torch-_inductor/_config.py"
They're all there.
But it's just, like --
it's a good file, though.
It's a good file.
Daniel Han: Yes, exactly.
Just read that file.
Read that file and, like,
just turn on all that,
you know, try all of them.
There's a lot of combinations.
Maybe do, like, some binary
search or something.
And like, my view is,
like, you can get a lot
of performance by doing that.
But I feel like, you
know, as Mark said,
matrix multiplication is a
very complicated algorithm.
You know, humans have been
doing this for, like, ages.
I don't know what's the last
optimization, like, N --
Mark Saroufim: Is
that the final one
that we do before
computers figure it out?
Daniel Han: Oh,
yeah, maybe, yeah.
Like, it's very,
very complicated.
Like, even, you know,
Strassen and, you know --
even if you invent
a good algorithm,
it's also good to run as well.
Like, Strassen, for example.
It maybe could be useful,
but maybe it's not
that useful, right?
Because, like, GPUs
have caching, you know,
different layers of
memory hierarchy,
and it's not that effective.
But maybe, maybe reinforcement
learning might find something
interesting, like, you know,
exploiting the cache hierarchy
or something like that.
But I feel like maybe --
do you think Flash
Attention could be written
by -- I feel like that's.
Mark Saroufim: Yeah.
Daniel Han: And it didn't
see Flash Attention.
Do you think it could,
like, invent that?
Mark Saroufim: So okay, well,
like, I might eat my words here,
but, like, I do suspect Flash
Attention 5 won't be written
by a human.
Daniel Han: Oh.
Mark Saroufim: So this is, like,
my bold prediction,
but we'll see.
I mean, you can remind me
if I'm wrong in 18 months.
Rob Ferguson: Okay, next Build.
Mark Saroufim: Yes.
Rob Ferguson: We'll look
at Flash Attention 5.
Daniel Han: But I
feel like algorithms,
like gradient checkpointing.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah.
Daniel Han: If the model
never knew what gradient
checkpointing was, it probably
could figure out, okay,
let's do gradient checkpointing.
But it's such a
fantastic algorithm.
Like, I wouldn't even call --
Is it a technique or algorithm?
Like, it's just very hard
to invent these things.
And I feel like
humans have this, like,
you know, I wouldn't
say creativity,
more like they think
outside the box much more.
And I feel like -- so
AI models definitely
can think outside the box.
They can still do that, right?
Because they prod
every single, you know --
if you give it enough time,
it will probably figure it out.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah,
if you're getting
into simulations of things.
Daniel Han: Yes, exactly.
Rob Ferguson: But the
transformer model, generally,
it's trying to figure out how
to transpose something it's seen
somewhere or someplace else.
And so, if it has a
memory of this thing,
then it can try to transpose it.
But we still find that often
we need to open up other --
Daniel Han: Yeah,
handcraft stuff, yeah.
Like, flash attention,
gradient checkpointing.
These are, like, so powerful.
You know, it
revolutionized the industry,
just these two, for example.
Yeah. I guess, yeah,
Flash Attention 5
and 6 and 7 or whatever.
Yeah, okay.
Mark Saroufim: Yeah, I mean,
I certainly agree with you.
Like, I think from a
capability perspective, like,
where I've seen people
get the most sort of bang
for their buck is, like, let's
say, getting coverage of kernels
on alternative hardware.
Daniel Han: Oh.
Mark Saroufim: So like, let's
say you're using a welcome chip
where there isn't, like, a
big community around it.
Then you can use an AI and it
can, like, one-shot a kernel.
But it can really one-shot it
because there's just, like,
not enough humans on the
planet that can do it.
And the sort of, like, the
entry level to get, like,
something decent isn't that high
because the human attention
isn't all that high either.
But, like, once you
get to sort of, like,
problems where it's been
very competitive for humans
and you look at, like, let's
say, AI-generated kernels,
today they are still slop.
Like, they will be very long.
They won't be very clear.
They'll have a lot of fallbacks.
They'll fall back to
PyTorch a lot and give up.
If you push it even harder,
it'll, like, reward hack.
So like, we're not there yet, I
think, for the hardest problems.
But if your problem looks
like I have this, like,
variant of an RMS norm that
kind of looks like an RMS norm
but isn't quite one, and
I can look at, like,
Daniel's RMS Trident norm kernel
and change it, yes, like,
AI will 100% like one-shot
like these things today.
Rob Ferguson: Okay.
Before we get into rotations
and other kernel optimizations,
I think we'll up-level
a little bit.
So speculative decoding assumes
a stable output distribution.
As workloads shift towards
long-running agentic tasks
with variable output lengths,
where does that assumption
start to break?
Mark Saroufim: I don't know.
I haven't run spec-decoding
much, like, in prod, but, like,
the way I would figure it's sort
of, like, the same, as in, like,
you're not going to
be making, like,
very long-running,
like, predictions.
Like, those will probably
be quite brittle.
But if, like, let's
say you, like,
assume this is an
interactive workload
and you're basically reconsuming
all the past generated tokens,
I think speculative dec
should probably continue
to survive for a long
time as a technique.
I think what makes speculative
decoding really powerful,
I think, as a
technique, is that, like,
it basically takes workloads
that have the performance
characteristic of decode
and turn it into the performance
characteristic of pre-fill,
which is, like, always going
to be something GPUs want.
And so, as a result, while,
like, it might not be as useful
or a bit more useful or a bit
less useful, I just, like,
am highly suspicious that the
technique would ever die.
Like, I think in
some sense, like,
that plus disaggregated
serving, like,
techniques that really help,
like, bump up the, like,
NVIDIA stock, like, I
think they're very key
to the chip being
irrelevant in the future.
Daniel Han: If the acceptance
rate, like, drops, like,
if your distribution
changes too much,
then the acceptance rates
will drop sometimes.
And so maybe you might have
to recalibrate your
speculative decoding head
and stuff like that.
So I guess you will have
to, like, re-fine-tune
on the new distribution.
But yes, over time,
you can, like,
the acceptance rate will drop
as reinforcement learning,
okay -- I'm just guessing.
But generally, the
acceptance rate will drop.
And then you can, like, you
know, fine-tune it back up.
Yeah, it's just, like,
more efficiency, I guess.
Yeah.
Rob Ferguson: Absolutely.
I just think that, you
know, we, I think just
in the last two years,
we've seen a big change.
You know, we had what
I would call "talkers";
people basically would do
one command back and forth.
And then all of a sudden, you
get into the agentic world
where it's 40 to 100 for every
single task that's there.
And it's very, very
hard for people
to understand what drops off
when you send something
100 times away as, like,
where are the trade-offs
that are starting to form?
And at what layer
could those trade-offs
actually start to form in?
And so I suspect that any
optimization that's going
to maintain coherence or be able
to have longer lengths matters
more and more as we get
into agentic workloads
on the other side.
Daniel Han: Yeah, in, like,
long context, like, you know,
models are getting better
and better at long context.
But that is also a problem.
Like, if your, you know, run
is very, very, very long
and your Claude
Code or, you know,
whatever codex run is very long,
it will get dumber and dumber
and dumber and dumber over time
as you have to do compaction
or somewhere like that.
And then how do
we do compaction?
You know, like, which details
do we compact or remove?
It is a very complicated
engineering problem now.
I'm sure everyone's trying
to figure out this as well.
Rob Ferguson: Do you feel it's
also, like, a math problem?
Just like, if you're
soft maxing over, like,
a very large denominator, like,
all your values will be,
like, close to zero anyways,
and it's just noise.
Do you feel like
there's any ways out?
Like, any hot takes on soft max?
Daniel Han: I don't know.
Somehow remove it and
do something else,
like linear or something.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Daniel Han: Like, exponential.
Well, I guess soft
max is, I don't know,
exponentially weighted somehow.
I don't know.
Just some dynamic
weighting system.
Sounds more complicated, though.
Rob Ferguson: Yeah.
Daniel Han: And then the
loss function has to change.
Rob Ferguson: Yes.
Daniel Han: And then that's
even more problematic.
How do we do that?
Rob Ferguson: Yeah, there's
a lot of open questions,
I feel, for a very long time.
Daniel Han: Delete the soft max,
do linear, and
see what happens.
But then I don't know
how to do the prediction
of the next token, though.
What do we do about that?
Okay, so it's a bit
more complicated.
Okay, fine.
Rob Ferguson: Okay, so
there's much more I'd love
to talk about, but we're
going to be coming
up on time pretty soon.
So I think I'll up-level my
last question for both of you.
So you know, we've talked
to both a little bit
about training and system-side.
Both of you have described
layers of the stack
that were built for a
world that is changing.
So this is my question to close.
Given everything that
we've discussed,
where is the highest-leverage
place for a builder in this room
to put their energy right now?
And what are they going
to waste their time on?
Mark Saroufim: I have a
hot take on this question.
Which is, like, I think, like,
agents exacerbate, like, any
sort of Amdahl's law effects.
As in, like, let's say you
have an agent running an
inference server,
it's not going to get
bottle-necked by the inference,
it's going to get bottle-necked
by the time it takes
to start the server, which
is, like, bottlenecked
by the time it takes to
warm up CUDA graphs,
JIT compile kernels,
by the time it takes to
read things from a disk,
by the time it takes to do,
like, multi-threaded, like,
reads back to your checkpoints.
So like, I think what I found
very interesting about, like,
agents is that, like,
the bottlenecks might be
in sort of strange places.
So if you're, like, generally
passionate about systems,
I think you'll find something
that agents will find
very, very useful.
Daniel Han: My take is,
like, similar, but, like,
do less, do the maths first.
Like, you know, how did gradient
checkpointing come along?
You know, why was flash
attention invented?
You know, what is fused
cross-entropy loss
or something like that?
You know, what is standby mode?
You know, something like that.
And then work on kernels.
So like, most people in
my view, like, you know,
you will start
working on kernels,
I would say take an
opposite approach.
You know, do the maths,
do the algorithms first,
and then think, you know,
how to do the kernels.
And then definitely look at
the TorchCompile config file,
you know, read all of it.
You know, ask Claude
or whatever codex.
Read it through all.
You know, see which
flags are useful.
Do binary search and whatever.
Not binary search.
Like, binary grouping, like,
you know, enable 50% of it
and then see, okay, the other
50%, which one's faster.
And, you know, so on.
Oh, wait, that is binary search.
Bisectional or whatever.
I think it's called
bisectional or something.
But, yes, do that, and
it will be very useful.
Yeah.
Rob Ferguson: All right.
Well, I really want to
thank everybody for coming
and hearing us learn out
about kernels today.
And definitely check out both
Daniel at Unsloth and Mark
at Core Automate
now that it's public.
Mark Saroufim: Oh, yeah.
Rob Ferguson: And as well as
learn more about Fireworks.
Here's information
about our session.
And we'll try to hang out to
answer any questions you have.
Thanks so much.
Daniel Han: Thank you.
Mark Saroufim: Thank you, folks.
Thank you.
[ Music ]